solidaridad mundial luego de la
catástrofe en Turquía y Siria el
presidente Turco regiop erdogan se
pronunció luego de Los Dos Grandes
terremotos que golpearon a su país en
las últimas horas y que han dejado miles
de muertos y heridos erdogan anunció que
45 naciones han ofrecido ayuda con
equipos de búsqueda y rescate organismos
internacionales como la Organización
Mundial de la Salud también anunciaron
ayuda humanitaria pero la OMS advirtió
que las labores de rescate implican un
gran reto logístico especialmente en
Siria país devastado por varios años de
guerra
una gran crisis económica un brote de
cólera Y ahora esta crisis adicional en
medio de un invierno duro es casi como
la Tormenta perfecta y la convergencia
de todas estas crisis está provocando un
enorme sufrimiento
la Unión Europea reaccionó en bloque y
activó el mecanismo de Protección Civil
equipos de Países Bajos y Rumanía ya
están en camino por su parte Bulgaria
fronteri con Turquía envió dos aviones
con 60 bomberos y rescatistas Israel
cuya relación diplomática con Turquía ha
sido tensa atendió el pedido de auxilio
de ankara
a pedido del gobierno Turco equipos de
rescate y asistencia médica Esto es lo
que hacemos en todo el mundo y esto es
lo que hacemos en áreas cercanas a
nosotros
dado que también Se recibió una
solicitud para hacer esto por muchas
víctimas del terremoto en Siria de
instrucciones para hacer esto también
Rusia a través de suministro de defensa
ofreció asistencia médica a las víctimas
Mientras que el presidente
estadounidense Joe biden dijo estar
profundamente estremecido por la
catástrofe natural